So for the next quiz, I'm going to make this a little more interesting
and assume I'm not quite so picky about who my friends are.
I'm going to be friends with people whose name starts with either "D"
or the letter "N".
So now the question is: we're still going to define the procedure, is_friend
but I've changed my definition of a friend,
so now we assume that I'm friends with everyone whose name starts with
either the letter "D' or the letter "N", but no one else.
So this result would still be correct--that would be correct.
If we asked: is_friend a name that starts with the letter "N,"
let's say "Ned,"
then we should also get the result, True
So see if you can figure out how to define "is_friend" for this new definition.